[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السيئه
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من كياز مع حديث
القوات الاوكرانيه عن تصديها لموجه هجمات
جديده بالطائرات المسيره في جبهات البلاد
من الخرطوم نتابع هذه الصور تزامنا مع
معارك عنيفه بين القوات المسلحه وقوات
الدعم السريع تشهدها العاصمه منذ صباح هذا
اليوم
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
موجات هجمات متبادله بالمسيرات
تشملته بالارهاب النووي بعد استهداف مسيره
موقعا قرب محطه كورس النوويه ومع استقبال
اولى دفعات القنابل العنقوديه قائد القوات
الاوكرانيه يقول ان كييف لن تطلب اذنا من
شركائها قبل استهداف الداخل الروسي
بعد موجه الادانات الدوليه للانتهاكات في
السودان مطالب متلاحقه بالمحاسبه واشنطن
تنتصف الوضع بالمقلق وتدعو لجهد دولي
لملاحقه المسؤولين الامم المتحده تدرج
طرفي الصراع في قائمه لمرتكبي انتهاكات
الجنسيه تقارير حقوقيه عن احتجاز الدعم
السريع 5000 شخص حاليا والدعم يرحب بتحقيق
الجنائيه الدوليه في احداث دارفور وينفي
مسؤوليته
[موسيقى]
التوتر الصيني الامريكي يخيم على مناقشات
وزراء رابطه جنوب شرق اسيا بجين تدعو
واشنطن الى نهج عقلاني في علاقات البلدين
وبلانكا يرغب في قنوات اتصال مفتوحه معها
ويدعو لحريه الملاحه في بحر جنوب الصين
وفي محيط تايوان الصين تدفع بعشرات
المقاتلات والقاذفات والمسيارات والسفن
ضمن تدريبات رواشن تدعو لتسريع تسليم
اسلحه الى تايوان
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه تناولنا بالات وانعكاسات النقاشات
الدائره داخل لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه
بمجلس الشيوخ الامريكي بشان ما يعرف
بمشروع قانون حمايه الديمقراطيه في تونس
والذي يقترح تقليص التمويلات التي تستفيد
منها تونس ضد مساء لتعزيز المؤسسات
الديمقراطيه هناك وذلك وسط انتقادات
امريكيه وحقوقيه دوليه للوضع السياسي في
تونس ووضع الحريات العامه لاستطلاع ارائكم
من شان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي كيف يمكن ان تنعكس تلك التحركات
على مواقف الحكومه التونسيه وجاءت النتائج
كالتالي
28% قالوا ان تحركات الكونغرس ستدفع
الحكومه التونسيه نحو مزيد من الانفتاح
بينما صوت 72% لصالح خيار عدم تغيير
الموقف الرسمي تجاه الانفتاح السياسي
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلال قضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
تزامنا مع تشديد دولي على ضروره تمديدها
اردوغان يقول انه متفق مع بوتين على تمديد
العمل باتفاقيه نقل الحبوب عبر البحر
الاسود والرئيس الروسي يقول انها ستمدد
فقط اذا تم الوفاء بالوعود التي قطعت
البدايه اذا بتطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا مع التقارير عن هجمات متبادله
بالمسيرات بين روسيا واوكرانيا فقد اعلنت
كييف اسقاط مسيرات روسيه مهاجمه والتصدي
لمحاولات التقدم في خركيف ودانيسك في
المقابل اعلنت موسكو اسقاط مسيرات
اوكرانيه جنوب غربي البلاد استهدفت احداها
محطه كورسك النوويه وعلقت الخارجيه
الروسيه على الهجوم بالقول ان حكومات
النيتو ترعى الارهاب النووي الذي تمارسه
كييف حسب تعبيرها ومع استقبال اولى دفعات
القنابل العنقوديه قائد القوات الاوكرانيه
يقول ان كيف لن تطلب اذنا من شركائها قبل
استهداف الداخل الروسي
هل تحولت الحرب في اوكرانيا الى حرب
مسيرات يسقط الاوكرانيون 16 مسيره في هجوم
على مناطق التماس جنوب شرقي البلاد ذلك
بعد ساعات من هجوم روسي بالمسيرات على
العاصمه
لم يقف الاوكرانيون مكتوفي ليدي اطلقوا
مسيراتهم كذلك في العمق الروسي يعلن حاكم
فرنج الروسيه اسقاط ثلاث مسيرات اوكرانيه
المسيره الاكثر خطوره كانت تلك التي اسقطت
على بعد كيلومترات قليله من محطه الطاقه
النوويه في مقاطعه كورسك الروسيه الحدوديه
الهجمات الاوكرانيه دفعت الكرملي للتعليق
بالتاكيد ان الدفاعات الروسيه تعمل
بفعاليه ليست المثيرات وحدها التي تحلق في
سماء المعركه تصل قنابل عنقوديه الى
القوات الاوكرانيه تلك القنابل يقول
الاوكرانيون انها ستغير مجرى المعارك وان
الروس قلقون منها لانهم يعلمون مدى
فعاليتها في المقابل تحذر موسكو من ان
القوات الاوكرانيه لن تلتزم بالقيود عند
استخدام هذه القنابل او اختيار الاهداف
بهذا تكون هذه الادوات العسكريه صغيره في
حجمها كبيره في تاثيرها لكن الامر يتوقف
على من سيحسم الامر على الارض
[موسيقى]
هذا واقرت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه بان الهجوم
المضاد الذي تشنه القوات الاوكرانيه لا
يحرز تقدما سريعا اضافت ان الحلفاء
الغربيين لا يمارسون ضغطا على كياف في هذا
الصدد مشيرا الى ان اوكرانيا ترفض اجراء
اي مفاوضات مع روسيا قبل سحب قواتها
من بيروت معنا العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك عميد الياس
حنا ماذا يريد كل طرف ان يحقق من الاعتماد
على سلاح المسيرات
المسيرات لا تربح الحرب يعني هي
اله هي وسيله من وسائل الحرب الاخرى من
ضمن الاسلحه الاخرى هي الاقل كلفه الاكثر
فعاليه بالمعنى الاعلامي الى حد ما يعني
عندما نتحدث عن استهداف المفاعل النووي في
كورسك يعني هذا المفاعل هو مجهز ضد الحرب
ضد النووي ضد حتى الزلازل ولن تؤثر فيها
هذا هذه المسيره ولكن اليوم المسيره هي
المدفعيه بعيده المدى الاقل كلفه وهي لمن
ليس لديه سلاح طيران اليوم الاكثر استعمال
يعني على سبيل المثال روسيا تستعمل
المسيرات والقنابل والصواريخ الباليستيه
والكروز في نفس الوقت فقط لاستهلاك
واستنزاف واشغال الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ولكن المسيرات لن تربح الحرب
بالمعنى حسم الحرب ولكن راينا هجمات مكثفه
لهذه المسيرات الروسيه على كييف بالمقابل
اليوم ايضا هجمات لمسيرات اوكرانيه
استهدفت من بين من استهدفت هذه المحطه
النوويه في كورسك ما الرسائل من كل ذلك
الرسائل يعني السلوك الروسي هو استمرار
لمرحله منذ بدء معارك مخموت مع الجنرال
الروسي سروفيكين الذي اقترح القصف المستمر
والقصف الاستراتيجي لكل المرافق والبنى
التحتيه الاوكرانيه نحن اليوم في هذا
الاطار على سبيل المثال ال سي هناك معمل
اتفق عليه بين ايران وروسيا لتجميع وتصنيع
الشاهد في منطقه طرطاليستان اثنين هناك
معامل لتجميع المسيرات التركيه في
اوكرانيا كثره الاستعمال تؤدي في وقت من
الاوقات الى تحسين اداء هذه المسيرات ولكن
في اخر الامر من يحتل الارض هو الذي ينهي
الحرب خاصه في هذه الحرب الاوكرانيه وفي
هذا الاطار وانطلاقا من هذا الكلام عميد
الياس حنا كيف يمكن تقييم الحديث
الاوكراني اليوم الذي اتى كانه اشبه
باقرار ان الهجوم المضاد
لم يحقق التقدم المنشود حتى الان
طبيعي ال سي اليوم كان لدى روسيه اكثر من
اربعه خمسه اشهر لتحضير الدفاع المرن
فليكس كما يقال على عمق 30 كيلومتر واليوم
ما يفتقده الجيش الاوكراني هو الدفاعات
الجويه ضد القوى المتنقله على دفاع فيه
الالغام المضاده للدبابات والاشخاص فيه
الخنادق فيه الحفر المضاده للدبابات مع
تفوق جوي
روسي هذا الامر يزعج
الدفاعات يعني الهجوم الاوكراني الذي لم
يحقق حتى الان الا في منطقه بخموت تقدم
بسيط ولكن ماذا لو تحول هذا الهجوم المضاد
الى هجمات طويله الامد لا تحقق تقدم عملي
ويحدث فارقا على الارض على غرار ما كان
يحدث قبل هذا الهجوم المضاد ماذا لو وصلنا
الى هذه النقطه
اذا وصلنا الى هذه النقطه قد نذهب الى ما
يسمى بستيل ميت على الطريقه الكوريه
بالعام 52 تصبح المنطقه منطقه عازله وهنا
يدخل قرارات النيتو ال سي اعطاء ضمانات
امنيه اعطاء الاف 16 وبالتالي هي موضوع
الحمايه يعني منع تقدم روسي اكثر من
المنطقه التي تقدم عليها وهنا يدور الجدل
انضمام الى النيتو او عدم انضمام اوكرانيا
الى النيتو واضح شكرا جزيلا لك العميد
الياس حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ضيفنا من بيروت
تعتبر مدينه نيكو بول في مقاطعه زابوروجيا
اقرب المدن الاوكرانيه لمحطه زبوروجيا
النوويه التي يسيطر عليها الجيش الروسي
ومع الحديث عن احتمال تعرض المحطه لكارثه
نوويه هاجر اكثر من نصف السكان المكان وقد
دعت السلطات الاوكرانيه الاهالي الى
التزام الحيطه والحذر في حال وقوع كارثه
مدينه جنوب اوكرانيا اقرب المدن الى محطه
زفر نوويه
لا صوت هنا يعلو على صوت تحذيرات السلطات
من وقوع كارثه نوويه
مخاوف بدات اثارها في نفوس سكان المدينه
خائفه بالطبع اشعر بالهلع فوق كل هذا
الخوف لا املك مقومات الحياه اعيش وكانني
لا اعيش
لسدادات جديه لهذه الكارثه المحتمله على
الرغم من كل التحذيرات الحكوميه على الاقل
هذا ما تشري به النوافذ والابواب المشرعه
على عكس توصيه السلطات باحكام اغلاقها
ويبدو ان للناس اولويات اخرى
الماء العنصر الاهم الغائب عن المدينه
اذ يعاني الاهالي منذ اشهر غياب الماء
الصالح للشرب
معاناه تعكس مظهرا اخر من اثار الحرب
المستمره
القصف المتواصل كذلك زاد من مشاق الحياه
وتحول القسم القريب من النهر في المدينه
الى احياء خاليه من اي مظاهر للحياه لا
تستبعد السلطات قيام الروس باحداث اي
تفجير هناك
وترى في ان ما حدث فيك خوفكا اشاره على
ذلك
مبينه حجم المساحه التي ستتاثر بشكل كبير
ندرب الناس على كيفيه التصرف عند الكارثه
لكن الممارسه تختلف عن التطبيق ثلث مساحه
المنطقه سيتضرر بشكل كبير جدا افضل ما
نستطيع فعله هو الاجلاء
القسم البعيد عن المحطه من المدينه يبدو
الحال فيه افضل من سواه هنا لا تبدو على
الناس علامات الانشغال بهذه الكارثه
المفترضه
اذ صرفهم عن ذلك الانشغال بتدبر امورهم
اليوميه
لطالما كانت هذه المحطه مبعث فخر
للاوكرانيين فضلا عن كونها مصدرا مهما
للطاقه اليوم تتحول هذه المحطه الى اكبر
مصدر تهديد للبلاد يعد بتكرار كارثه
عاشوها قبل اربعين عاما عمر الحاجه
الجزيره من مدينه بول المقابله لمحطه
النوويه
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات في السودان فبتزامن مع تجدد
الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في مناطق مختلفه من الخرطوم تتصاعد
الدعوات للمحاسبه وتتسارع التحركات
الدوليه بعد اعلان المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه فتح تحقيق اتهامات لدعم السريع
باعمال قتل في دارفور الدعم السريع اكد
عدم ضلوعه في القتل ورحب باي تحقيق اما
واشنطن فقد وصفت الوضع في دارفور بانه
مقلق للغايه وناشدت المجتمع الدولي دعم
جهود محاسبه المسؤولين عن الانتهاكات
هو ذات مشهد الحرب في السودان بين الجيش
والدعم السريع يتجدد كل يوم في مواقع
متعدده بالعاصمه السودانيه وغيرها حسب
المصادر العسكريه فان عمليات الجيش امتدت
من شمال مدينه الخرطوم بحري الى جنوبها
وجرا قصف عدد من مواقع الدعم السريع
وبينها ارتكازاته في احياء المهندسين
والمنصوره في ام درمان لكن الدعم السريع
ذكر في بيان له في هذا الشان ان قواته صدت
محاولات الجيش للهجوم على تلك المواقع
تزايدت الدعوه في اروقه عديده خلال
الساعات الاربع والعشرين الماضيه بضروره
ايقاف الحرب وتتحدث الامم المتحده عن
زياده مقلقه في حالات الاعتداء الجنسي
وغيره من الانتهاكات في جميع انحاء
السودان كما بدات المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه التحقيق في الانتهاكات الجاريه في
غرب دارفور
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
يوسف عزت رحب في حديث مع الجزيره باي
تحقيق في المزاعم بارتكاب جرائم حرب في
مدينه الجنينه نرضي دارفور ونفع عزت اي
تورط لقوات الدعم السريع في احداث الجنينه
مضيفا ان التحقيق سيكشف المتورطين وشدد
عزت على ان هذا الموقف يتفق مع بيان الدعم
السريع حول ما جرى في الجنينه ووصفت
المندوبه الامريكيه في المنظمه الدوليه
الوضع في دارفور بانه مقلق للغايه ودانت
ما سمته بالفضائع التي يرتكبها الطرفان
ودعت لوقف القتال والقتل الجائر للمدنيين
فورا وناشدت المجتمع الدولي دعم جهود
محاسبه المسؤولين
وسبق ان اعلنت بريطانيه انها تفرض عقوبات
على الشركات المرتبطه بالجيش والدعم
السريع والتي تغذي الصراع وحسب وزي فان
العقوبات تستهدف بشكل مباشر الذين ادت
افعالهم الى تدمير حياه الملايين في حرب
غير مبرره على حد قوله الثابت وحسب اعلان
مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه ان اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين شخص
نزحوا داخل السودان او لجاوا لدول الجوار
منذ اندلاع الحرب في منتصف ابريل الماضي
وان انعدام الامن وما سماها المكتب
بالعوائق البيروقراطيه يعرقلان وصول
الامدادات الانسانيه للمتضررين وتشدد
الجهات الاغاثيه الدوليه على ضروره الوصول
العاجل الى المحتاجين خاصه في دارفور
لتجنب حدوث كارثه مع دخول الفصل الخريف
ومن جديد يبرز السؤال المتعلق بمدى نجاح
هذه الضغوط المتزايده في ايقاف الحرب او
على الاقل في دفع المبادرات المطروحه حول
القضيه والتي لم تتجاوز حتى الان مرحله
روايه القصه التي يعرفها الجميع
في سياق ذاته قالت ممثله الامين العام
للامم المتحده المعنيه بالعنف الجنسي في
حالات النزاع براميلا باتن ان اعمال عنف
جنسي واختطاف للنساء والفتيات وثقت في
السودان منذ اندلاع صراع هناك في شهر
نيسان ابريل الماضي وقالت باتن ان الامين
العام للامم المتحده ادرج في تقريره
السنوي بهذا الشان كلا من قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني في قائمه الاطراف
المشتبه بارتكابها اعمال عنف جنسي ضد
النساء في السودان
عند السودان
في السودان ومنذ ضلع النزاع في ابريل
الماضي تلقى مكتب الامم المتحده لحقوق
الانسان تقارير موثوقه عن انتهاكات ضد
اكثر من 50 امراه وفتاه وفي هجوم واحد فقط
تعرضت نحو 20 امراه للاغتصاب وتلقيت هذا
الاسبوع معلومات اضافيه عن استهداف
الموظفين والبنيه التحتيه الطبيه التي
توفر دعما لضحايا العنف الجنسي فضلا عن
زياده عمليه اختطاف النساء والفتيات وقد
ادرجت كل من قوات الدعم السريع وقوات
الجيش من قبل الامين العام في قائمه
المشتبه في ارتكابهم انتهاكات وابلغ طول
جنرالايين البرهان واحمد بالتدابير التي
يتعين عليهما اتخاذها في هذا الشان
افادت وكاله رويترز ان منظمات حقوقيه
سودانيه لديها ادله على احتجاز الدعم
السريع نحو خمسه الاف شخص بينهم 3500 مدني
في ظروف غير انسانيه اضافت هذه المنظمات
التي رفضت كشفه هويتها خوفا من الملاحقه
انا من بين المدنيين المحتجزين نساء
واشخاص من جنسيات اجنبيه واكدت انه
بامكانها تقديم مستندات الى الامم المتحده
توفق حالات قتل تحت التعذيب وافتقار ظروف
الاحتجاز لمقومات الحياه الاساسيه من
جهتها نفت قوات الدعم السريع هذه التقارير
واكدت ان عناصرها يحتجزون فقط اسرى الحرب
ويتلقون معامله جيده
اليه عمل المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
والمسارات التي ياخذه تحقيق ياخذها
تحقيقها في التقرير التالي
[موسيقى]
تختص المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بالنظر في
جرائم الاباده وضد الانسانيه والعدوان
تبدا اجراءاتها بطلب من دوله طرف فيها او
من مجلس الامن كما يمكن للمدعي العامل
للمحكمه نفسه المباشره في التحقيق وهو على
ما يبدو ما حدث مؤخرا بشان احداث دارفور
الاخيره غربيه السودان تقليل المدعي العام
اشار الى ان المحكمه غير قادره حاليا على
العمل في السودان بسبب الوضع الامني لكنه
سيبدا بذلك في اقرب وقت ممكن يتضمن الشروع
في التحقيق عاده جمع الادله وحضور
واستجواب المتهمين والمجني عليهم والشهود
وحتى طلب التعاون من دوله او منظمه حكوميه
عند تشكل القناعه لدى المحكمه بارتكاب
الجريمه يصدر امر القبض على المتهم او امر
حضوره في حال الادانه يمكن ان تصل العقوبه
الى الحبس المؤبد او الى الحبس 30 عاما
كما يمكن للمحكمه فرض غرامه ماليه والحجز
على الممتلكات القرار وقتها ليس نهائيا
فمن حق المتهم استئناف قرار المحكمه
الاخير لحدوث خطا في الواقع او القانون او
الاجراءات يحدث ان تبدا المحكمه اجراءاتها
وتصدر قرارات رغم عدم حضور المتهم مثلا في
عام 2005 حالا مجلس الامن الوضع في دارفور
على المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه على خلفيه
نزاع مسلح بدا عام 2002 ثم اصدرت المحكمه
عام 2009 2010 مذكرتي اعتقال الرئيس
السوداني انذاك والمعزول لاحقا عمر البشير
وافراد الاخرين من نظامه بتهم ارتكاب
جرائم حرب وضد الانسانيه وجرائم اباده في
احداث دارفور رفض البشير التهمه جمله
وتفصيلا وسافر عام 2010 الى تشاد وكينيا
ولم تسلمه مع انهما دولتان طرفان في
المحكمه الجنائيه
بقي توضيح وصف المدعي العام بتكرار
التاريخ البائس في دارفور قتل في ذلك
النزاع بين الحكومه وجماعات مسلحه قبل نحو
20 عاما قرابه ثلاثمائه الف وشرد اكثر من
مليونين ونصف المليون شخص وفق تقارير
الامم المتحده
معنا في الاستوديو الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني خالد الاعسر مرحبا بك سيد خالد
كيف يمكن تقييم
النقطه التي وصلت اليها هذه المواجهات
العسكريه والتي يبدو انها تتخذ طابعا اكثر
ضراوه وعنفا
بالتاكيد تحيه لك ابتداء ولمشاهديكم
الكرام بالتاكيد خلال المرحله الماضيه
كانت
الفكره اعداد المؤسسه العسكريه الممثله في
القوات المسلحه لما هو قادم باعتبار ان
قوه الدعم السريع كانت تبني خطه مبنيه على
مراحل منذ عوام مضت بدءا من تكوين قوات
على على الارض ثم التشوين بعدد كبير من
الاسلحه النوعيه وحتى العمليه التي انتهت
بالعنصر المفاجاه المؤسسه العسكريه ظلت
تحتمي في مغاره تحصيلا لمؤسسات الرسميه
حتى تبدا عمليه كروه فرع وهذا يبدو واضحا
اليوم العمليه التي تمت في مدينه بحريه
عمليه هجوم نوعي كبير ربما هي الحاله من
الحالات عنه وماذا الى ماذا ترمي هذه
العمليه خصوصا في ظل حديث الدعم السريع عن
انه تصدى لها بنجاح عن اسر الضباط او او
عناصر من الجيش وعن الاستيلاء على مركبات
عسكريه المبالغه في الارقام كانت واضحه
صحيح ان الحرب هي كروه خسائر بالتاكيد
الجيش حقك اختراق كبير وعبر كبري وصل الى
مدينه بحري ويخدم على عمليات عسكريه نوعيه
كبيره الان
وبالتالي ليس غريبا ان تكون هناك خسائر في
الحرب وان كانت الخسائر من ابناء الوطن
الواحد امر مرفوض ولكن هم اختاروا طريق
الحرب والجيش عن شعبه الخسائر التي وقعت
اليوم ليست كما حاولت تصوير قوات الدعم
السريع هناك خسائر نعم هناك اعتقال لاسرى
نعم ولكن ليس بالحجم الذي ذكر وبالتاكيد
هذا يدعو لي ارسال رساله لقوات الدعم
السريعه لا تتمادى في هذه العمليه
العسكريه يجب ان تحقق المرحله الماضيه
يعتمد على الطيران الان يبدو انه غير
الخطه او الاستراتيجيه
بالذهاب نحو هجوم بري ماذا نفهم الذي يجب
ان يفهم لدى الجميع ان هناك احياء في ام
درمان وفي عدد من البطول الخرطوم وحتى في
الخرطوم بحري الان تشهد حاله عوده
للمواطنين وعوده الحياه الى طبيعته هذه
الاماكن كانت تسيطر على قوه الدعم السريع
في عنصر المفاجاه
وبالتالي هذا ايش بان هناك تقدم نوع كبير
للجيش السوداني وفي المقابل يدعو لارسال
رساله لقوات الدعم السريعه ان هذه المعركه
في النهايه ساحسم الجيش ايا كان طوله ولكن
من الاولى لها قياده قوات الدعم ان كانت
تسمع للمناشدات عليها ان تستجيب لكي يعني
تضع السلاح جانبا وتحفظ ارواح هؤلاء
الشباب من الذين تبقوا من قوات الدعم
السريع وعندما اذكر تبغ هناك تقارير
استخباراتيه دوليه ذكرت وفاه عدد اكثر من
47 الف جندي من قوات الدعم السريع هذا
التقرير امريكي يوزع لدى الذي يريد ان
يعرف عميقه الاشياء نردد لغات الدعم
السريع ان حجم القوه العسكريه من حيث قدر
العسكريه واليات وعدد افراد في 15 ابريل
يكاد يكون معدوم اليوم بما هو عليه الحاله
الان اذا لماذا الاصرار والامان على عمليه
انتحاريه هذا السؤال يجب عليه قياده قوات
الدعم السريع ان كانت كل هذه المعارك
العسكريه الدائره على الارض الان دخل على
الخط موضوع
الغربيه في دائره ضيقه اذا طالما تمهت مع
فكره يعني دفن الرؤوس في الرمال امريكا
بريطانيا الاتحاد الاوروبي الان اصبحوا في
مواجهه مع شعوب الغربي في الدول اوروبا لن
يقبل ان تكون القامه هناك حكومه اوروبيه
تدعم قوات ارتكبت جراين ضد الانسانيه
المحلل الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني
شكرا جزيلا لك ضيفنا هنا في استديو الحسن
الى شرق اسيا حيث خيم التوتر الامريكي
الصيني على اجتماع وزراء خارجيه رابطه دول
جنوب شرق اسيا اسيا ففي حين اكد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه رغبه واشنطن في ابقاء
قنوات اتصال مفتوحه مع بيجين الا انه
حذرها من اي اجراء يستهدف الاقتصاد
الامريكي كما دعا الى حريه الملاحه في بحر
جنوب الصين في المقابل دعا كبير
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين الولايات المتحده
الى نهج عقلانيا في صياغه علاقات البلدين
في اجتماعات وزراء خارجيه دول جنوب شرق
اسيا حضر ممثل ثمانيه عشره دوله لكن
التركيز كان منصبا على وزراء خارجه الثلاث
دول تؤثر خلافاتها في المنطقه والعالم وهي
الولايات المتحده والصين وروسيا لم تشهد
اجتماعات اسيان اي لقاء ولو قصيرا بين
وزيري خارجيه روسيا والولايات المتحده بدا
ان جسور الاتصال منقطعه بين الطرفين حاليا
بسبب اوكرانيا لكن الامر يختلف بين الصين
والولايات المتحده التقى وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن بكبير
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين في اطار السعيد
احتواء الخلافات ومن ابرزها ما يتعلق
بمنطقه اسيان تطرق برينكن الى القرصنه
الاخيره بمؤسسات امريكيه تقول واشنطن ان
مصدرها الصين وطلب ونجي بوقف تدخل
الامريكي في شؤون الصين الداخليه تبقى
تايوان التي تعتبرها الصين جزءا من ترابها
وشانا داخلي اكبر مصدر للخلافات الامريكيه
الصينيه لكن الخلافه يتسع في منطقه الشرق
اسيا ليشمل النزاعات الحدوديه بين الصين
ودول ابرزها الفلبين وفيتنام في بحر جنوب
الصين كما لا تغيب النزاعات الاقتصاديه
خصوصا بشان العقوبات الامريكيه على الصين
في مجال التكنولوجيا والرقائق الالكترونيه
بالتحديد خلال لقاء على هامش اجتماعات
اسيان جمعه بوزيره خارجيه اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه قال برينكن ان اكبر تحد لامن
الدول الثلاث هو كوريا الشماليه لكنه فتح
فيما بعد الباب لحوار دون شروط معها
نواجه تحديات اخرى مع كوريا الشماليه
كاطلاق صواريخها في تجارب متكرره تهدد
المنطقه والعالم وحالات انتشار الاسلحه
وانتهاكات حقوق الانسان وكما قلنا سابقا
بشكل علني لكوريا الشماليه فنحن مستعدون
للدخول في حوار دون شروط مسبق لكن للاسف
كان جوابها على هذا المقترح باطلاق مزيد
من الصواريخ
يشير بنك الى صاروخ باليسي اطلقته كوريا
الشماليه واختارت ان يكون ذلك قبل ايام
قليله من انعقاد اجتماعات اسيا يعرف
الامريكيون العلاقه القويه التي تربط
الصين بكوريا الشماليه وربما يعد هذا من
الاسباب التي تدفع واشنطن الى ابقاء جسر
الحوار مفتوحا مع بيجين
نقلت شبكه سي ان ان عن مسؤولين امريكيين
حدوث اختراق صيني لانظمه بريد الكتروني
حكوميه بما فيها وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
وانا الاختراق منح الصين معطيات عن توجهات
واشنطن قبيل زياره بلنكن الى بيجين كما
نقل موقع اكسيوس عن مصدر مطلع ان عمليه
الاختراق استمرت شهرا قبل ان تبلغ وزاره
الخارجيه بل تبلغ شركه مايكروسوفت بوجود
انشطه غريبه في شبكتها وذكر المصدر للموقع
ان القلق يزداد في واشنطن بشان
استراتيجيات الامن السيبراني لشركه
مايكروسوفت وان اسئله ما تزال موجوده عن
كيفيه سرقه المتسللين مفتاح التشفير
وتمكنهم من الولوج الى شبكه مايكروسوفت
في هذه الاثناء نقلت صحيفه ووستريت جيرل
عن رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه الامريكيه
الجنرال مارك ميلي قوله انه يجب تسريع
مبيعات الاسلحه الامريكيه وتسليمها الى
تايوان لثني الصين عن القيام بعمل عسكري
ضد الجزيره على حد تعبيره وقالت وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه انها اجازت بيع اسلحه
متنوعه لتايوان تشمل صواريخ مضاده للسفن
مضيفه انها مررت الصفقه الى الكونغرس
متحدث باسم الوزاره افاد بموافقه واشنطن
على صفقه بقيمه 665 مليون دولار لدعم
انظمه الرادار التايوانيه وهي الصفقه
الاكبر في عهد بايدن
قالت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه ان الصين
ارسلت منذ يوم الثلاثاء عشرات المقاتلات
وقاذفات القنابل والمسيارات وان بعضها عبر
الخط الفاصل في مضيق تايوان واقتربت الى
مسافه 24 ميلا بحريا من سواحل تايوان كما
قالت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه ان الطائرات
الصينيه حلقت جنوبا وعبر بعضها قناه باشي
التي تفصل بين تايوان والفلبين واتجهت نحو
المحيط الهادئ برفقه سفن حربيه صينيه وقال
مسؤول امني تايواني انشطه الصين التي تاتي
قبل تدريبات بلادها العسكريه السنويه هي
جزء من حرب نفسيه تشنها على تايوان وفق
تعبيره
من روما معنا الدكتور لورينز وترمين استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه الدراسات
الدوليه والخبير في الشؤون الاسيويه مرحبا
بك دكتور لورينزو ماذا نفهم عن نتيجه هذا
اللقاء
بالنسبه لانعكاسه على العلاقه الامريكيه
الصينيه
شكرا جزيلا على
الاستضافه يسرني الانضمام اليكم بالنسبه
الى هذا الاجتماع الاسيوي
فنتائجه كانت سطحيه جدا بالنسبه الى
العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه لان الاجتماع
هو له علاقه بالاقتصاد والتعاون الاقتصادي
بين دول جنوب
اذا هذا الاجتماع كان راكدا حاليا ان صح
القول
عندما التقى وزير الخارجيه الصيني
والامريكي فقد كان ذلك اجتماعا تحضيريا
للقمه بين رئيسي الدولتين
اعتبر انها مقاربه تكتيكيه
هي جزء من الاجتماع او تحضير للاجتماع
الاستراتيجي الاوسع في الخريف المقبل ماذا
نفهم من الكلام الصيني عن ضروره ان تتبع
واشنطن نهجا عقلانيا في العلاقه ماذا تريد
عمليا الصين
بالنسبه الى موضوع تايوان اعتقد ان هناك
تناقض لابد لنا من توضيحه اعتقد انه هناك
نقطتان في موضوع تايوان لدينا الافق
التكتيكيه القصير المدى اولا وعلى اساسه
يمكننا ان
نفسر حركات الولايات المتحده وجهودها
بالنسبه الى تايوان كنوع من التحريك لهذا
الوضع القائم اي ان واشنطن تحاول ان تغير
في هذا الوضع القائم من خلال دعم
مساعداتها لتايوان لانها فعلا قلقه من انه
على المدى الاطول تحاول الصين ان تغير في
الوضع القائم من خلال السيطره على الجزيره
عسكريا اقتصاديا او بالقوه اذا على
المستوى او على المدى القصير تكتيكيا
تحاول الولايات المتحده تعميق علاقاتها مع
تايوان ولكن على المدى الاطول استراتيجيا
تقلق الولايات المتحده من محاولات الصين
فرض توحيد الجزيره واعاده ضمها اذا هناك
مديان هنا افوقان ونرى الافق القصيره
الامد كمحاوله امريكيه لتغيير الوضع على
المدى الاطول الوضع يختلف وايضا من
الاجانب الامريكي دعوات لابقاء قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه مع الصين
توازيها دعوات
لتسريع تسليح تايوان كيف ايضا نفهم هذا
السلوك
نعم اعتقد ان قنوات التواصل هذا
حيث اننا راينا مسؤولين هما من الارفع
مستوى وحتى على مستوى قمه بين
الرئيسين قمه مباشره هذا امر ممتاز صراحه
لانه من شانه ان يخفض من التوترات خلال
الازمات دعونا لا ننسى
ان التصعيد امر معتاد في بحر جنوب الصين
حيث راينا اكثر من مره
مناورات كادت تصل الى مواجهه بين السفن
الامريكيه والسفن الصينيه في مضيق تايوان
اذا يجب فعلا ان تالاف هذا الموضوع
ويجب ان تبقى هذه القنوات قنوات التواصل
مفتوحه التي من شانها ان تجنبنا هكذا نزاع
شكرا لك من روما الدكتور لورينز وترم
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه دراسات
الدوليه والخبير في الشؤون الاسيويه
[موسيقى]
في اخبارنا الاخرى قالت مجموعه محامون من
اجل العداله انها رصدت اكثر من 300 حاله
اعتقال سياسي في الضفه الغربيه منذ بدايه
العام منها اكثر من 80 منذ بدايه مايو
الماضي وقالت المجموعه ان نشطاء وطلب
وصحفيين هم من بين المعتقلين ومنهم الناشط
مصعب اشتيا المعتقل منذ اكثر من عشره اشهر
بالاضافه الى عبد المجيد حسن رئيسي مجلس
اتحاد الطلبه في جامعه بيرزيت المنتخب
مؤخرا واشارت المجموعه الى ان نفي الناطق
باسم الاجهزه الامنيه وجود اعتقال سياسي
في الضفه يعتبر استخفافا بحريات الناس
وحقوق الانسان حسب وصفها
اعلن محامول مؤسسه الليبيه للاستثمار عن
رفع دعوى جنائيه في بروكسل ضد الامير
البلجيكيلو رام بتهم الاحتيال والابتزاز
عبر سعي للحصول على اموال من مشروع فاشل
لاعاده التشجير في ليبيا جاء ذلك خلال
مؤتمر صحفي في العاصمه البلجيكيه يذكر ان
الامير لورا وهو شقيق ملك بلجيكا وقع عقدا
مع السلطات الليبيه عام 2008 لاعاده تشجير
مناطق صحراويه في ليبيا وانهار المشروع مع
اندلاع الثوره في ليبيا عام 2011 وتقول
المؤسسه الليبيه للاستثمار ان الامير سعى
للحصول على مبلغ يقارب 70 مليون يورو عبر
رفع قضيه ضد المؤسسه ثم مارس ضغوطا عليها
بدعوى قدرته على التاثير على مسار التحقيق
قالت منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله يونيسف
في تقرير حديث ان التقديرات تشير الى وفاه
او اختفاء ما لا يقل عن 289 طفلا هذا
العام اثناء محاولتهم عبور طريق الهجره
المحفوف بالمخاطر في البحر الابيض المتوسط
قادمين من شمال افريقيا الى اوروبا وهذا
ما يعادل وفاه او اختفاء ما يقارب احد عشر
طفلا كل اسبوع وهم يحاولون البحث عن
الامان والسلام وفرص افضل اضافت اليونيسف
ان نحو
11,600 طفلا وصلوا الى شواطئ ايطاليا هذا
العام قادمين من شمال افريقيا اغلبهم
كانوا بمفردهم ودون عائلاتهم ومنذ عام
2018 تقدر اليونيسف ان حوالي 1500 طفل
ماتوا او فقدوا اثناء محاولاتهم عبور
البحر المتوسط ودع التقرير الى العمل على
خلق مسارات امنه وقانونيه للاطفال للحصول
على اللجوء مع تعزيز الجهود لانقاذ
الارواح في البحر الى جانب معالجه الاسباب
الجذريه للمساله
في اول تحرك من نوعه لمواجهه الذكاء
الاصطناعي صوت قاده اتحاد الممثلين في
هوليود للانضمام الى كتاب السيناريو في
اول اضراب مشترك منذ اكثر من سته عقود ما
ادى الى اغلاق استوديوهات الانتاج في لوس
انجلوس بكاليفورنيا وقالت نقابه الممثلين
الامريكيين ان الدخول في الاضراب هو
الملاذ الاخير للعاملين في هذا القطاع في
ظل التعسر المفاوضات مع شركات مثل ديزنيكس
وامازون ويرفع كتاب السيناريو والممثلون
عددا من المطالب من ابرزها الحصول على
رواتب اعلى وتوفير ضمانات بالا يحل الذكاء
الاصطناعي محل عملهم وحذرت رئيسه نقابه
الممثلين الامريكيين فران من ان الممثلين
يستبدلون تلقائيا بتقنيات بتقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي
في تداعيات الانسانيه للمواجهات الدائره
في السودان استقبلت ولايه الجزيره وسط
السودان اعدادا كبيره من الفارين نتيجه
الحرب الدائره بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع بالخرطوم وقد اقامت سلطات
الولايه مراكز والاسر النازحه داخل
وفي منطقه حنتوب شرقيه الولايه وتبذل
منظمات مدنيه ونشطاء محليون جهودا حثيثه
لمساعده الفارينه من الحرب وتوفير
احتياجاتهم الاساسيه رغم شح الموارد وطول
امد النزوح
لم تسلم فاطمه من ويلات حرب طاحنه دارت
رحاها بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع بالخرطوم ولم تجد بدا من مغادره
منزلها وصولا الى احد مراكز الايواء
بمدينه ودمدني حيث انجبت طفلها في ظروف
انسانيه قاسيه
فيقولنا نسافر نجي هنا طوالب والدنيا
المستشفى
بحسب تقديرات الحكوميه بولايه الجزيره في
السودان فان اكثر من 150 الف اسره وصلوا
من الخرطوم الى ولايه الجزيره هربا من
جحيم الحرب يتوزعون بين مراكز الايواء
المؤقت ومنازل الاسر المستضيفه بالولايه
توجه حكومه ولايه الجزيره انه ما حنفتح
معسكر يعني بتاع نازحين للمعنى المفهوم
الواضح المعمول به في العالم كله نحن
اشتغلنا بطريقه يعني يمكن يكون قبل كده ما
اشتغلت ما في دوره اشتغلت
في ولايه الجزيره ولايه عطاء وكرم جود
هذه المدرسه تحولت الى مركز لاواء اكثر من
60 اسره اغلبهم نساء واطفال
يحاولون التغلب على ظروف المعيشيه صعبه
باتت تؤرق حياتهم غير ان الاطفال هنا
يرسمون لوحه لواقع يبدو اكثر تفائلا قد
ينسيهم ذكريات اليمه رسمت الحرب فصولها
الحالكه
في حوالين بيتنا في بيت جيراننا يعني وكان
هلع والطياره ذاته لما تجي بندخل تحت
السراير طبعا وكنا خايفين خوف شديد كان
شويه ظروف ما سمحت لنا نطلع بدري طلعنا
اخر ناس
الجهات الحكوميه تقول انها وفرت اكثر من
150 مركزا للاواء بولايه الجزيره في
موازاه مبادرات لمتطوعين تحاول هي الاخرى
تخفيف ماساه من شربتهم الحرب بتوفير اماكن
للايواء وخدمات الرعايه الطبيه للمرضى
ناهيك عن تامين الغذاء ومياه الشرب بجانب
احتياجات اساسيه اخرى
[موسيقى]
الى ان تضع الحرب اوزارها سيعيشها هؤلاء
على وقع ذكريات تركوها خلفهم وامل العوده
اليها في اقرب وقت
اسامه سيدي احمد الجزيره من مدينه
الجزيره وسط السودان
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى التطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا نركز في فقره في المتابعه على
عدم اليقين السائد بشان تمديد اتفاقيه
تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه فقد افادت وكاله
بلومبر بارتفاع قيمه العقود الاجله للقمح
والذره وقد اكد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان اتفاقه مع نظيره الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين على مساله تمديد العمل بالاتفاقيه
وقال اردوغان الذي انخرطت بلاده في
المفاوضات لتوقيع الاتفاقيه ان المحادثات
لتمديدها ستتواصل من جهه قال الرئيس بوتين
انه لم يتم فعل شيء لروسيا في اطار صفقه
الحبوب وشدد بوتين على انه بامكان روسيا
تمديد صفقه الحبوب فقط عندما يتم الوفاء
بالوعود التي تم قطعها وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن بدوره حظ روسيا
على تمديد الاتفاق محذرا من ان العالم
النامس سي عاني اذا لم يحصل ذلك حسب قوله
كما شدد الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو على اهميه التوصل لاتفاق من اجل
اعاده بناء الثقه مع العالم النامي
الاتفاقيه الى التخفيف من خطر المجاعه في
العالم من خلال ضمان تسويق المنتجات
الزراعيه الاوكرانيه رغم الحرب ينتهي
الاتفاق الخاص بصادرات الحبوب الاوكرانيه
الحالي في السابع عشر من هذا الشهر من هذا
الشهر اتاحت الاتفاقيه التي تفرض تفتيش
السفن من قبل ممثلي الاطراف الاربعه
الموقعه تصدير نحو 33 مليون طن منذ دخولها
حيز التنفيذ اغسطس عام 2022
وتم تصدير غالبيه الحبوب الى دول ناميه في
افريقيا والشرق الاوسط وانحاء اخرى من
العالم وتمكن برنامج الاغذيه العالمي من
توفير 725 الف طن من القمح للدول التي تمر
بازمه مثل افغانستان واثيوبيا وكينيا
والصومال والسودان واليمن
ينضم الينا حول هذا الموضوع من انقره
المحلل السياسي مراد اصلان ومعنى من موسكو
المحلل السياسي ديمتري بابتش مرحبا بكما
سنبدا معك سيد مراد اصلان على اي اساس
باعتقادك اكد الرئيس التركي انه اتفق مع
نظيره الروسي على تمديد الاتفاقيه وهو ما
لا يبدو حاصلا حتى الان
اذا شعور من قبل الامين العام للامم
المتحده او دعوه له وكان هناك ايضا دعوه
من السلطات التركيه والسفاره
وبعض المفاوضات بالنسبه لتمديد اتفاقيه
الحبوب نعرف ان روسيا لديها شروط مثل
تخفيف من العقوبات المفروضه عليها وايضا
تصدير ايضا مسميدات لدول اخرى وتريد ايضا
تغييرا كبيرا في البروتوكولات لانها تريد
ان تبيعها اعتقد انه بعد ان تقوم تركيا
واوكرانيا والامم المتحده
باستيفاء الشروط او المطالب ستكون روسيا
راضيه من جهه اخرى الدول الغربيه يجب ان
تلتزم او تمتثل
لمطالب روسيا لان الضمانات
المعطاه للسفن الروسيه عاليه وايضا تريد
ان تحد من
التدخل بالنسبه الى وصول المنتجات الروسيه
الى الاسواق وبالتالي هذا تقوم بمثابه
صفقه سيدي متري بابتش روسيا تقول انه لم
يجري الالتزام بما جرى التعهد به لروسيا
في المرحله الماضيه ما نوع الضمانات التي
تريدها روسيا في هذه المرحله من اجل تجديد
هذا
اعتقد ان هناك سوء فهم
المصادر الروسيه تفيد بان اردوغان قال انه
كانت لديه نفس التصور للمشكله مثل الرئيس
بوتين الوكالات الروسيه لم تقول ان
اردوغان اعلن ان الصفقه تمت وكل شيء سيكون
ممتازا والاتفاقيه سوف تمدد بعد 17 من
يوليو اما بالنسبه الى الشروط التي وضعتها
روسيا اعتقد انها واضحه اولا
الحبوب الروسيا ايضا يجب ان يسمح بتصديرها
المعاملات الماليه والتبولات التبادلات
الماليه يجب ان تتاح مناخ خلال البنك
الزراعي الروسي وكذلك روسيا تريد للحبوب
الاوكرانيه التي تتوجه الى دول الغربيه
كما حصل في السنه الماضيه تريد روسيا ان
توجه الى ادوى الفقيره فكره ان هذه الحبوب
الاوكرانيه توجهت الى بولندا ودول اخرى من
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتبر فضيحه فعلا وهذا
مثبت لان المزارعين البولنديين
اعترضوا
وتظاهروا خلال العام اعتراضا على دخول
الحبوب الاوكرانيه
اسواقهم اذا مره اخرى غشنا الغرب
واخذ الحبوب الاوكرانيه المستفاده منها
ولم يساعدها الافريقيه ودول الشرق الاوسط
الفقيره الحبوب الروسيه ستوجه الى افريقيا
والشرق الاوسط تساعد والفقيره الحبوب
الروسيه والصادرات الروسيه على الارجحيه
اكبر من الصادرات اوكرانيا سيد مراد اصلان
اذا اذا السيده متري بابتش يقول الغرب
غشنا هل في هذه المرحله تركيا بعد ما
المشهد الذي رايناه في قمه النيتو وهذا
التقارب
الحاصل بين تركيا ودول غربيه والولايات
المتحده تحديدا هل تركيا في هذه المرحله
قادره على توفير هذه الضمانات التي تريدها
روسيا من اجل تجديد الاتفاق
الجانب الروسي اعلن
ما هي مطالب
رئيس الروسي ولكن هناك قبول بان تركيا جزء
من حل شمال الاطلسي تركيا صارت معتبه
بوابه لتمرير مطالب روسيا الى الدول
الغربيه بحسب الدول الغربيه مره اخرى
اوروبا
مسروره بتواصل تركيا مع روسيا اذا انه هي
استراتيجيه مفيده للطرفين بحيث انها تتيح
الدبلوماسيه بالنسبه لاتفاقيات الحبوب على
وجه الخصوص تركيا تريد ان تعزز هذا
الاتفاقيه وربما بالحصول على
تعهدات اخرى بالنسبه او استيفاء لمطالب
روسيا ولكن احيانا مطالب روسيا تاتي
متناقضه يريدون قدره نفاذ الى الاسواق وفي
الوقت نفسه يريدون ان يعفوا من هذه
العقوبات
الغرب لا يفرض عقوبات كامله على روسيا
هناك روسيه يحق لها ان تحول الاموال
الغربيه اذا يجب ان يكون مستوى اعلى من
التعاملات او من تداولات ولكن تركيا تلعب
دورا على الاقل
تتيح مجال التفاوض هذا
الدور التركي كيف تنظر اليه روسيا في هذه
المرحله لاسيما كما ذكرت بعد قمه الناتو
هذا التقارب الواضح مع الغرب وايضا بعد
معطى استجد في الايام الماضيه تمثل في
اعطاء او الافراج عن مقاتلي كتيبه ازوف
وتسليمهم الى الجانب الاوكراني وهو ما
اعترضت عليه روسيا
اعتقد ان روسيا
تظهر الكثير من الصبر بالنسبه الى موضوع
تركيا لان تركيا انتهكت الاتفاقيه حين
سمحت لهؤلاء المقاتلين او القاده الخمسه
من كتبه ازوف بالعوده الى اوكرانيا
الاتفاقيه التي وقع عليها اردوغان وبوتين
افترضت انهم سوف يبقون في تركيا حتى نهايه
الحرب ولكن مقارنه مع قضاء اخرين من حلف
شمال الاطلسي فان السيد اردوغان شخص
ديمقراطي
اللطيف ومنفتح لان ما قيل عن روسيا خلال
هذه القمه كان فظيعا حتى قارب النازيه ان
صح القول وقال ان روسيا ولو هزمت ستبقى
تهديدا اذا بالنسبه لروسيا فاردوغان هو
بمثابه وسيط ينظر الى تركيا على انها من
الدول القليله ذات السياده في عالمنا الان
التي ليست معتمده تماما على الغرب الان
سيد ديمتري لو وصلنا الى يوم السابع عشر
من هذا الشهر ولم نعرف او لم تعلن روسيا
انها تقبل بتمديد الاتفاقيه ماذا سيكون
عليه الحال
الحبوب الاوكرانيه تتوجه حين ذاك عبر
بولندا والمرافع البولنديه الى اوروبا
ربما ايضا تمر بمراء المرافق والموانئ على
نهر الدانوب اعلنت الحكومه انها تحضر لي
انهاء التي الغاء ابطال الاتفاقيه ولكن
اذا ابطلت
سوف يكون ذلك معيبا سيكون خطا الغريب
ولكنه معيب لانها كانت اتفاقيه ممتازه لو
نفذها طرفا وليس روسيا فقط شكرا لك سنكتفي
بهذا القدر المحلل السياسي ديمتري بابتش
من موسكو وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من انقره
المحلل السياسي السيد مراد اصلا شكرا لكم
بهذا مشاهدينا ننهي حصاد هذه الليله شكرا
لمتابعتكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]